a newly elected member of Congress is
apologizing for criticizing supporters
of Israel after a blast from her own
party leadership Minnesota Democratic
Ilhan Omar appeared to criticize her
colleagues for taking money from the
Jewish lobby she later apologized in a
statement saying anti-semitism is real
and I'm grateful for Jewish allies and
colleagues were educating me on the
painful history of anti-semitic tropes
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with
more on this story Nancy good morning to
you good morning and in that apology
Omar said that she never meant to injure
or hurt her constituents particularly
her Jewish constituents and this apology
comes after she issued a pair of tweets
over the weekend suggesting that AIPAC
the pro-israel lobbying group has bought
the support of her colleagues this is
not however the first time that Omar has
had to apologize for tweets that some
see as having anti-semitic overtones a
couple of weeks ago she said she was
sorry for this tweet from 2012 in which
she said quote Israel has hypnotized the
world now Omar is one of the first
Muslim women in Congress she's one of
just a couple of members of Congress who
support a movement known as BDS which
calls for a boycott of Israel until
property can be returned to Palestinians
yesterday her House Democratic
colleagues circulated a letter calling
on leadership to take action on what
they called hateful speech and how
Speaker Nancy Pelosi did just that
issuing her own blistering statement
calling Omar's tweets anti-semitic and
deeply offensive Republican leaders in
the house however want Pelosi to go
further and strip Omar of her seat on
the House Foreign Affairs Committee and
President Trump who has gotten into
plenty of hot water for his own language
said that she should be ashamed and that
her apology bianna did not go far enough
all right Nancy thank you